Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Daniela Rus.
I'm a roboticist
and the director
of MIT's Computer Science
and Artificial Intelligence
Laboratory, or
CSAIL as we know it.
And also Deputy Dean of Research
in the Schwartzmann College
of Computing.
Welcome to today's installment
of Hot Topics in Computing.
Now, our guest today
needs no introduction.
But I'd like to give
him a short one anyway.
Neil Degrasse Tyson is an
astrophysicist and arguably
the world's most well-known
science communicator.
For nearly 25 years, he
directed the Hayden Planetarium
at the American Museum
of Natural History,
while also writing
dozens of books
and hosting beloved TV shows
and podcasts, such as Cosmos,
StarTalk, and Nova.
Neil received his bachelor's
degree in Physics from Harvard
and his PhD in Astronomy
from Columbia University.
And in addition to his degrees
and his extraordinary presence
in the media, Neil
received more than a dozen
honorary doctorates,
as well as many awards.
And what I would like
to highlight today
is the NASA Distinguished
Public Service Medal,
which is the highest
award given by NASA
to a non-government citizen.
He's even got an
asteroid named after him.
Neil, I'm so delighted that you
made time in your busy schedule
to join us today, to continue
the conversation we started
in December, to talk not
just about the stars,
but also how astrophysics
relates to the computer science
world.
So Neil, welcome back virtually.
Welcome to MIT.
Yeah.
Well, thank you.
Thanks for having me back.
I love your audience.
It's always inquisitive, and
energetic, and with a verve
for learning and
asking questions.
And so I'm all in.
I'm all in for all of that.
So let's move on.
Sorry.
I hope you're ready, Neil.
Because back in December,
I had about 200 questions
from our amazing students
left after our conversation.
And that number has doubled.
So let's get started.
OK.
Let's do it.
That's just a question
every 20 seconds.
That's not a problem.
OK.
Let me start with some questions
around the rise of data and AI.
Do see potential in AI to
solve general questions
about the universe or will
AI be used to crunch numbers
and equations?
Yeah.
So I don't see AI getting ahead
of us in our cosmic inquiries.
Now, maybe that's just
because I don't want it to.
And so I accept that
bias that I may have.
I think I recognize that bias.
But so much of the
questions we ask
about the universe come about
by looking up and saying
to ourselves, hmm, that's odd.
That doesn't match
what it should--
that's unusual.
Isaac Asimov, great author
and an science writer
over many decades, he
made the perceptive point
that true scientific
discovery, contrary to what
we think of with--
was it, not Aristotle,
but Archimedes-- contrary
to what the legend
would have you believe,
true scientific discovery
doesn't come from somebody
saying Eureka!
It comes from somebody
saying, hmm, that looks odd.
[LAUGHTER]
What's going on there?
So I guess, AI, if it's
a complete mapping of all
that it is to be human, that
I suppose, in principle, you
could inculcate it with
a sense of curiosity
so that it will explore things
it doesn't know and then
bring to bear on it what it
does know to try to solve it.
I don't see why that
couldn't be the case.
But I don't know that we
have good examples of AI--
yes, we have AIs
finding solutions
to problems that
had eluded people.
I knew that took place
in chess and in Go.
Even in something as
simple as juggling,
there were solutions
to these tasks
that we've had for so
long, that they just
found another solution to it.
But would the computer be
able to invent another game,
for example?
I'm still wondering
whether I can
get the full sort
of abject creativity
that we know humans
are capable of?
Is AI going to paint
this behind me?
Is it going to come--
will it even think to
paint something like that?
So I don't know.
And I think cosmic
exploration is so--
every year, it's like
who ordered that?
What?
Oh, two black holes colliding.
Oh, let's try to measure that.
OK.
Oh, the universe is expanding.
Oh, the universe
is accelerating.
had a beginning.
Oh, there might be a multiverse.
I don't see AI anywhere
on that landscape.
So I know it's your
whole bread and butter.
But I'm thinking it'll be a
long while if ever before AI
is sitting right next to me,
scratching our head-- whatever
the AI scratches--
to try to figure out
a new question and a new problem
that sits in front of us.
So for me, it's
the data crunching
that happens once we've already
established the problem.
And now we want to
calculate upon it.
Oh, in an ideal
world, if you could
have anything out of an AI
or machine learning system,
what would you like
as an astrophysicist?
Oh.
Huh.
I was thinking what
would I want as a person?
Let me answer that first.
Yeah, I'm ready for
self-driving cars.
I'm ready for that.
Nice comment, Neil.
I'm working on it.
Are you, OK.
Well, hurry up.
OK, all right.
I got two kids who
don't want to drive.
One is like 20 and
the other is 24.
And I'm from the city.
They don't want to drive.
And they're waiting for you
to send the self-driving car.
I mean, they're coming, slowly.
What I like especially
about the self-driving car
is that it will know about
all other self-driving cars
in its vicinity.
So if it had to change
lanes, it just tells them
I'm changing lanes.
And then they part the seas.
The car changes lanes.
And so the sources
of so many accidents
would just evaporate overnight.
And you'd have a safety
factor that is the--
we're still losing a
hundred people a day
to car accidents on the
freeways, and highways,
and pedestrians in
the United States.
So that would take that to near
zero, if not identically zero.
In astrophysics, let me think.
I-- hmm.
You see, AI--
I'm-- forgive me.
But I keep thinking
of AI as a tool
to help me do what I'm
doing rather than what
I think a full-up AI
should be capable of doing,
which is completely
replacing me.
I send the AI to my office,
and let it handle all the phone
calls, and write the book.
Because if it's true AI, then
it should be just like me
or better, especially better.
And so I don't know where to
put the dart into the AI table
to say, this is where
I want it versus this
is where it will ever reach.
So I don't-- that's probably
a very unsatisfying answer.
But I still think of AI as
just really good computing,
helping me solve the
problems that I posed
and the questions that
I am investigating.
Well, Neil that's a view
that's consistent with many
of our viewers.
We're just trying to make
the tool more capable.
And someday, I hope
we have a chance--
I could tell you about how long
till those self-driving cars
do what you just like.
But since we're talking
about AI and tools,
what computing technology
from today would
you have the most
trouble living without?
Oh, definitely the smartphone.
I think the smartphone is the
greatest thing ever conceived
and invented in the
history of civilization.
I don't think anything
comes close to it.
And it happened in our lifetime.
And by the way, any
generation would
say that about whatever they
might have invented, right.
Let's go back 140
years or 30 years.
The telegraph, oh,
my gosh, that's
going to change the world.
Oh, we could-- and they lay down
a cable across the Atlantic.
You talk to Europe, when it
used to take you however long
to sail.
And so sure, when you're on
an exponential growth curve,
if you are anywhere
on that curve,
It will feel like all the
greatest discoveries happen
just in the few recent years.
So it's not that you're
living today in a golden era.
The entire era is a golden
era because everything
is happening exponentially.
And so where do I come off
then saying, the smartphone
is the greatest thing ever?
Just simply because of what
technologies it has merged.
It takes better photos than
most people ever took ever
in the history of the world.
More photos are being taken.
And this started out as a
telephone, a freaking phone.
OK.
And I remember the
early camera capacities.
There was a fuzzy photo.
And it was wasn't good.
And it was just like
for an emergency.
Now, that's my camera of
choice on my telephone.
Oh, wait, it's not a telephone.
It's not only a telephone.
It's access to the whole
world's information.
Oh, plus, where do I make the
tour to get to grandma's house
and avoid the traffic?
Let me check the phone.
And it's getting information
from satellites, satellites
that has precision timing.
And the timing is
so precise it has
to be corrected for Einstein's
general theory of relativity
because of the time dilation,
for it being so high up.
Actually it's the
opposite of time dilation.
The satellites are so far
away from Earth center,
and Earth as a
source of gravity,
that time ticks
differently for it.
And if it's giving you the
time that you think you need,
it has to correct for that
before it hands it down.
So this is a technology that
is using relativity, space
physics, internet, photography.
And I'm thinking,
what's left to do?
So if I were to
go back and bring
one thing to show Isaac Newton,
it would be the smartphone.
Well, I'm excited you really
like the technology that was
produced by our field broadly.
Do you have any
theories about it?
And, in particular, maybe
connecting it to AI?
What is your biggest
fear with respect to AI?
We know that last year you
agreed with a fellow podcast
guest, who said that the
world's largest existential
crisis is within AI.
What are you afraid of?
And has your opinion
changed since then?
I don't think I--
if I agreed, it
might have only just
been a mild agreement.
We've all seen the
movies with AI gone bad.
And often-- I don't
if I said this
when I was last your guest.
But the science fiction
writer Ray Bradbury, famously,
in response to a question posed
to him-- the question was,
Mr Bradbury why do you write
these future stories of such--
of science gone bad
and apocalyptic earth.
Is this the future you
think we're going to have?
And he, said no, I
write these stories
so you know what
future to avoid.
So I don't mind the
apocalyptic movies.
They sell tickets.
And they're always
kind of interesting.
And maybe that'll help reset
our cautionary urges to say
I don't want that to happen.
No, that's pretty bad.
Oh, that-- OK.
And that's true, of
course, for any technology.
I think there are other more
tangible existential threats
than AI.
And that's why I part ways with
even AI experts, who say this
and feel this.
For me, the question is not,
will AI take over the world?
For me, that's not
the right question.
The right question is,
when you have AI ability,
what are you most likely
going to do with it?
And I don't see anybody--
maybe in your basement
you doing this.
And you're not going
to tell anybody.
But personally, I don't--
and I've been on--
I've been-- OK, I'm not like
total computer engineer.
But I've had my
days on computer,
I probably coded 50,000 lines
of computer code in my life.
Most of that in graduate school
and shortly thereafter that,
and in college.
About 50,000 lines,
that's respectable.
But it's not as much as
real professionals at it.
But I have enough
of a baptism to I
think-- that my thoughts
have some foundation.
That's really what I'm
trying to say here.
So when I think of computers
and what role they play,
my first thought
is not, let's have
the computer do everything.
That's just not my thought.
My thought is, let me
get a computer that
makes a perfect cup of coffee.
Do I need that computer to
guide my self-driving car?
No.
Do I need my self-driving
car to run my laptop?
No.
Do I need-- so if
you're going to now say
AI will be all of
this, all wrapped up
into one humanoid bot,
who's going to do that?
I can't picture that
as anybody's priority
because anything you
roll up into one thing,
I don't think is going to be as
good as the very specifically
tasked computing
tool that is applied
to specific things in your
life, making it better,
and perhaps even perfecting it.
So I know general
AI is supposed to be
able to do all of the above.
Is it going to
walk my dog for me?
Is it going to--
is it going to go
to the beach for me?
People talk about, oh,
we're going to upload
our brains into computers.
And then we're in the computer.
I'm going to take a
stroll on the beach
and meet three people.
Did the computer do that?
No.
OK, so it's not me anymore.
Me, I continue living a life
of a flesh and blood human
being because I have two
legs and I can walk down
the frickin' beach.
Whereas the computer on the
shelf, it can think about it,
I suppose.
It can imagine meeting
new people, I suppose.
And maybe that's good enough.
And maybe the difference
doesn't matter.
Like in the movie, The
Matrix, if it's just
all in the head, who even
knows and who even cares?
Maybe we're all in
the Matrix right now.
But I just don't see
the all-purpose computer
taking over everything.
I just don't see that.
I agree.
Let me move on to
the next question.
Oh, can I add one thing?
Sorry.
Again, I don't remember
if I said this last time.
I'm old enough to
remember The Jetsons.
This is a Hanna-Barbera
cartoon, that coexisted in time
with The Flintstones.
It's interesting to have the
stone age and the future all as
prime time cartoons,
half-hour cartoons,
that were part of the canon
of what I grew up with.
And in there, of course,
he's in a flying car.
Of course, it's the future.
And he's up in the
clouds, of course.
So what do you have?
Well, they have a robot maid.
And it looks like--
it's wearing like a maid thing.
And so the maid is pushing the
buttons to clean the laundry
and to do the things.
And I'm thinking, no,
you don't need the maid
to push the button.
Let the laundry machine
be the computer.
You don't need a robot to get
in your car, to drive your car.
Your car is the robot.
So all of these movies
that show humanoid
Robots who's going to do that?
No.
I've seen some attempts at it.
I don't see any people lined
up to get a human robot walking
around their house.
And if the demand
isn't there, the supply
is not going to be there.
So I don't see it.
Sorry.
In fact, with that, it's
interesting to think
about robotic technologies
over the past 50 years.
Many robots were actually
inspired by the human form,
with arms and humanoid shapes.
But we can robotize everything
I need in the built environment.
We can create so
many more shapes.
And that's where the
robotics future is.
Very important.
And let me echo that because
the idea that you would create
a robot that's humanoid
comes with the implication
that the human form
is some ideal thing.
No.
I mean, wouldn't it be
great if you had eight arms,
like an octopus?
That would be like really--
you could be really effective.
I mean, just be a little
more creative about that.
To create another human,
I don't need that.
I love humans.
I don't need you to
make a robot human.
No.
Yeah.
So you tune the
robot for the task
physically, kinetically,
so that that task is
perfected by the morphological
form of that robot.
And you know
something, when you've
done that, that robot is not
the robot making your morning
coffee or your laundry.
And it's not the one
driving your car.
And we have a number
of students working
on exactly those problems.
But let me move on and ask
you about more astrophysics.
Harvard's Avi Loeb
argues that Oumuamua
was an interesting
stellar alien probe.
What do you think?
He was able to get
very few people
to agree with that conclusion
among his colleagues.
So we can talk about
this outlaying idea.
And part of what made
it get so much attention
is his academic
affiliation with Harvard.
You barely ever saw his
name without Harvard,
chair of the Harvard department.
So Harvard was-- he would
ride in that sort of Harvard
affiliation, in the recognition
he was getting for those ideas.
Very few people
aligned with that.
But apart from-- and
by the way, in science,
if you have a really--
you can have crazy ideas
that turn out to be true.
But generally, the effort to
establish that truth is you
go through peer review.
And they say, no,
you forgot this.
And, no, you forgot to cross
the T, dot the I, carry the 2.
And if you can't get colleagues
to embrace what you just
came up with, then
maybe you should
rethink what you're doing.
That's the whole
point of peer review.
So anyhow, his paper by the way
that suggested Oumuamua being--
just to make sure we're
all on the same page, we,
the astrophysics community,
discovered our very first--
we've been looking for
these for decades--
our very first
interstellar visitor
coming through the solar system.
And you can determine
that instantaneously
by establishing its
orbital parameters--
not instantaneously, you get
a few positions of its orbit.
And you know, is it
on a hyperbolic orbit,
is it on an elliptical orbit?
If it's hyperbolic, it does not
belong to this solar system.
This we knew from Jump Street.
It did not belong
in the solar system.
It got a lot of attention
because of this.
Then we noticed--
we, the people who--
the asteroid-- the
solar system folk--
noticed that it
had what's called
an anomalous acceleration.
You add up the gravity of
all the planets, and the Sun,
and everything else
you know about,
and it's moving a
little extra than what
the gravity that should
be influencing it
could account for.
And so-- by the way, that's not
so weird in the solar system.
Comets exhibit
this all the time.
Why?
As they near the Sun, heat from
the Sun sublimates the ices.
And you can get ice jets--
gaseous jets creating thrust
on what's otherwise a nicely
Newtonian path,
thereby disrupting
what you might otherwise think
is the perfect laws of gravity.
The problem with
Oumuamua is, nobody
saw any jets coming out of it.
There was none of this
telltale cometary fuzz.
And so that meant
it was a conundrum.
So people for a while said, we
don't know what's causing this.
Avi Loeb jumped right
in and said "aliens."
And that's just
not my first guess
at something if I
don't know what it is.
I'm going to work--
I'm going to really--
I will scratch my head
more before that's
the conclusion I land on.
Because if everything
you don't understand you
want to credit aliens, I
don't know-- what is that?
And it turns out some
geologists figured it out
it's probably outgassing
of a kind we're not
familiar with on solar
system style comets.
It is after all,
from another place.
So it easily accounts for it.
But Avi had his sort
of day in the Sun,
where everybody wanted to
hear how it is that aliens
are visiting our solar system.
By the way, half you
all are physics--
this MIT, right.
So you all are physics fluent.
So anomalous acceleration was
a single extra force operating
on it, that altered its path
from what would otherwise
be a pure Newtonian trajectory.
I'm thinking if
it's aliens, they
would zigzag through
the solar system.
They're not going to
still be on a smooth path.
If they have controlled
acceleration, my gosh,
nothing is stopping it.
And if it did a planetary
tour, and hung out, checked out
the Earth, then I'd say, Avi,
let's revisit that suggestion,
that maybe aliens
are in control.
So that's what you have there.
Oh, by the way, the
monitoring of the sky
for things that go
bump in the night
is the sole task of a very new
telescope, which was previously
known as the Large Synoptic
Survey Telescope, LSST.
It got renamed thankfully to
the Vera Rubin Telescope, one
of the more famous
members of our community,
who discovered dark
matter in galaxies.
She died a few years
ago, Vera Rubin.
So it's called the
Vera Rubin Telescope.
This telescope-- and
it dovetails back
to your whole existence here.
This telescope-- forgive me,
I'm not fluent in the numbers.
I'd have to look them up.
And they're very lookable.
But it's basically going to take
a snapshot of the entire sky
multiple times a
night, thereby making
a movie of the night sky.
Now, you say to
yourself, why do you need
a movie if nothing changes?
Well, how do you
know nothing changes?
You've never had a movie of it.
And there are other
things where you
can-- if you only observed
something at the same time
each night, suppose something
blinks on once every 24 hours?
You'll think the thing is
constantly in the same state
because you don't have data from
the rest of the phasing of what
that thing has
happened-- is doing.
This telescope is
going to solve that.
And it is the
largest data project
there ever was in my field.
And it is almost
entirely computing.
There's the pipeline of
data that gets analyzed.
And there's a
serendipity mode, where
it gets automatically
analyzed and compares it
with an image the night before
or earlier in that night.
And if anything is different--
[SNAP]
--it goes back to it
and signals other people
to possibly turn other
telescopes onto that zone.
So this is modern
astrophysics that
would be impossible without
very clever programming
of the management
and analysis of data.
Where should the Vera Rubin
Telescope look for life?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, if it's coming in on a
flying saucer, it'll find it.
But if you're going
to look for life
chemically or in
other ways, you want
to send a probe, maybe
to the planetary surface,
as we've done with Mars,
the Perseverance rover.
It's called a rover.
But it's really a
mobile biolaboratory.
And it's also got some
geophysics tools in it as well.
We don't have a word
for Mars geology
because "geo" means Earth.
So Mars geology, it's
kind of a misnomer.
But anyhow, it's doing these
experiments in an attempt
to establish, and
understand, and characterize
the environment on Mars,
so that we can pose
the next round of questions?
Was there ever life there?
Is there life there now?
If it's there now,
is it underground,
and how far underground?
And if there's water
there, is the water liquid,
is there a heat source that
we haven't reckoned before?
All of these questions get
asked in the search for life.
But I can tell you that
if a flying saucer comes
through our airspace,
the Vera Rubin Telescope
is going to catch it early.
Speaking of looking
for life on Mars,
do you expect to see
life in the seas of Titan
in our solar system?
So Titan-- so let's--
so just again, to
catch people up.
Titan is one of the
moons of Saturn.
And, in fact, it's
one of the biggest
moons in the whole
solar system actually.
And it has an atmosphere.
Oh, my God, a moon
with an atmosphere.
Well, if you have an
atmosphere that means
you can establish
partial pressures
on things that might then
be sustained as liquid.
Once you lose your atmosphere,
liquids are not stable.
And they just evaporate out.
So if Titan has an atmosphere,
let's look for liquids.
And what's the
atmosphere made of?
Well, it's mostly methane, CH3.
So you got methane.
But Titan is way out there.
Jupiter's far enough.
Now, you double that.
And you get to Saturn.
And the moon around
Saturn, that's
way outside the Goldilocks zone.
So we're not going to
expect liquid water.
No, I don't think.
So you get there.
And there are these boulders.
Because we've landed
on the surface--
a European probe, attached to an
American orbiter around Saturn,
Huygens Probe, named
after Christian Huygens,
a polymath, a Dutch polymath,
from the era, from the 1600s--
and 1700s.
So he-- the Huygens
Probe deployed
and descended onto
the surface of Titan,
through the atmosphere.
And it's able to make a soft
landing-- because there's
an atmosphere, you can
just use a parachute.
When we landed on the Moon,
you couldn't use a parachute.
You needed to spend fuel to
prevent yourself from crashing.
This is part of the
fuel budget that you
have to consider
depending on where you
want to go in the solar system.
So here's Titan.
But then you ask, well, what's
the temperature of Titan?
And I forgot what it is.
But it's cold enough
to liquefy methane.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, if we can liquefy methane,
and there's partial pressures
to keep it liquid, we
should look for lakes.
And, oh, my gosh, we found
lakes, methane lakes on Titan.
They were closer to the
poles than we had thought.
Maybe they'd be more
towards the equator.
So-- all right, well,
where's the water
because really water is not
uncommon in the universe?
Oh, the water is
frozen into bedrock.
So here on Earth when we see
rocks, we say rocks are solid.
No, rocks are solid
at room temperature.
Go inside a volcano,
rocks are liquid.
So what is water on Titan?
It is frozen solid.
It is the bedrock.
And those are the mountains.
Those are water.
And the liquid is
liquid methane.
So let's ask the question,
what does it take to have life?
Are we going to
invoke a water bias
and say, life as we know it.
It's got to have liquid water.
So let's look for liquid water?
Maybe all life really
needs is liquid.
And maybe methane--
liquid methane--
is a whole-- is a foundation
for a whole other kind
of life form, that our
imagination prevents us
from conjuring because we are
so earth-biased in our biology.
So I like the question,
could there be life on Titan?
Because if there is,
it will completely
stretch our understanding of
all the ways of being alive.
What chemistry do expect
non-DNA form to use?
So here's an interesting--
let me sort of not answer
that question, with
another comment.
If you speak to geologists,
and they look at Mars,
they see rocks.
And they say, oh,
there are iron oxides.
And there's silicates.
And they can use
the same vocabulary
that they use on Earth
when they're talking
about the rocks on Mars.
So what it means is minerals--
geology as a general field--
is highly portable
in your understanding
of processes from one
rocky planet to another.
Well, if that's-- let's call
that a universal thing that
minerals do under certain
temperatures and pressures.
Should we not presume that
the way life formed on Earth
wouldn't be exactly the way
life would form anywhere else?
Should we require that
identity gets encoded in ways
that do not invoke DNA?
When geologists are not
saying, oh, here's an element,
we've never-- no.
We've got the elements.
We've got the periodic table.
Planets are not
inventing new elements
that we haven't
already discovered.
We've got that, OK.
So could it be that
biological processes
are as repeatable as
the formation of rocks?
That's an interesting question.
And if that's the
case, then we could
declare that the DNA molecule
is an inevitable consequence
of complex chemistry.
And no longer have to
ask ourselves, what
would life be like without DNA?
So that's a way to not
answer your question,
but with another sort of
probing thought about this.
And by the way, life on
Earth formed really fast.
We've been around 4
and 1/2 billion years.
The first half a billion, the
conditions on Earth's surface
were very hot.
We were still accreting
material from the solar system.
So that would break
apart complex molecules.
The binding energy is less than
the impact energy of rocks.
So then, finally,
we cooled down.
Now, we can make
complex chemistry.
Start the clock
at that point, it
took a hundred million
years for life to show up.
Yeah, that sounds
like a long time.
But what's a hundred million
years compared with 4 billion?
So left to itself,
Earth made life.
And so why should I think--
and just because we have a hard
time making life in the lab--
we haven't figured it out yet.
We got the top
people on it though.
Just as we haven't
figured it out,
doesn't mean nature
didn't figure it out
or that nature won't figure
it out wherever it has
access to complex chemistry.
And as your audience
surely knows,
all the ingredients of life,
the hydrogen, the oxygen,
the silicon, the
carbon, all of that
are the most common ingredients
across the universe.
So if we were made of
a isotope of bismuth,
you could say, yeah, life
is rare, life as we know it.
We're special.
But, no, no, the
top three chemically
active ingredients in
the universe in order
are the order in which you
find them in life on Earth.
Excuse me.
It's the top four.
So hydrogen is the number
one element in life.
The number two element in
the universe is helium.
But it's chemically inert.
It doesn't count.
What's next?
Carbon, oxygen, these
next two elements
are two and three
in the universe.
And so oxygen is more
abundant than carbon.
And that's what we're made of.
So life was really opportunistic
with its ingredients.
And plus, we got carbon
in the middle of it,
which is extraordinarily
sticky, chemically sticky.
Man, it can bind to itself,
with its four electrons.
And it can bind
with another four.
It'll get two, two, and two.
It can get one, one, one, and
one-- so one, one, and one.
And it can make
long chains, just
like what the double helix is.
So anyhow, I'm going to vote
for the double helix, at least
for now.
That's great.
OK, more about our universe.
Is our universe expanding
within a different universe?
I'm sorry.
Are we expanding--
Is our universe expanding
within a different universe?
Oh, yes.
So let me shape
that up a bit here.
So we have modern understanding
of the application
of quantum physics to the
early universe, the Big Bang
basically.
It allows us-- if you only use
Einsteinian physics for the Big
Bang, it's kind of limiting.
But when the whole
universe-- quantum physics
is the physics of the small.
And general relativity is
the physics of the large.
But at the Big Bang,
the large was small.
So if the large is small and
rivals the sizes of particles,
then you get to apply
quantum rules that
impact the entire universe.
That's a fun place to hang out.
It's also a shotgun
wedding there
because the two don't really
play well in the sandbox.
You need a third understanding
of how this works.
And this is what string
theorists come in
and other high-level
cosmologists.
But when you follow some natural
consequences of this marriage,
one of the thing-- and with
an inflationary scenario--
inflation, Alan Guth, an MIT
professor, one of the pioneers
of that concept--
when you invoke this,
you learn that this thing
can make multiple universes,
multiple expanding bubbles.
And so if that's
the case, then we
are one expanding bubble inside
of a larger universe, that
has other expanding
bubbles within it.
Now, you could be
an expanding bubble
in an expanding universe,
where everybody is expanding.
And you'll never actually
bump into one another.
If the universe is expanding
faster than your bubble is,
for example.
So then you'll never catch up.
And that's an
interesting scenario.
You can rank these multiverses
by their simplicity
or their complexity.
And that one would be the
simplest example of one.
Because these other
universes still share--
in a way, they share
our space-time.
They'd have the same
laws of physics.
They might have a
different amount
of matter in them or whatever.
And there could be an
infinite number of them.
In this book, that just
came out a month ago--
can I show it?
Is that--
Go ahead.
Cosmic Queries.
I've got to show it there--
This is a book that's collected
the deepest questions we've
ever asked about the
universe in the history
of our civilization.
So in here is how did
it all begin, how did it
get to be this way,
what is it all made of,
how will it all end?
And there's a whole
section here on,
what does nothing have
to do with everything?
Because how do you
define nothing?
Is it where there's no matter?
Well, suppose there's energy?
OK, let's take away the energy.
Is there no quantum phenomena?
Let's take that away.
Well, there's still the
fabric of space and time
getting curved by gravity.
Let's take that away.
Well, then there's still the
laws of physics that apply.
Let's take that away.
So what does it mean then
to have a region of space
where you don't even have
laws of physics that apply?
We go there in this
book because there's
a category of questions that
are just dangling by our ankles
off the cliff.
And we're dangling
there because we don't--
let's just-- is the question
even the right question
that were asking?
So that's one
category of universe.
A whole other
category of universe
allows the different multiverses
to have different laws
of physics within them.
and they get more and
more spooky and scary,
actually for me, because I
lose sleep over some of these.
And so it's a fun
exercise in pushing
the limits of your
physics and your math
to see what fate awaits us.
And for me, the scariest
fate is the possibility
that the accelerated
expansion of the universe--
this is that dark energy
you may have read about.
If that goes
unchecked, then that
stretching of the
fabric of space and time
will overcome the elasticity
of space-time itself.
And when that
happens, it will rip
at the pixelated level of
what the universe-- of what
constructs the universe.
And that's the Planck length.
This Planck length,
all right, that
is the quantization
of the universe
that general
relativity doesn't see.
That's why you needed a third
theory to put them together.
But that pixelization of
the universe, as you expand,
there's a point where
it wants to expand that.
How do you expand the basic
building pixel of the universe?
You can't.
So it's called the Big Rip.
And if it goes
unchecked, that'll
happen in about
20 billion years.
So that's what I
really lose sleep on,
if you want to talk
about other universes.
Time to move to
another universe then.
Speaking of our own universe,
how will our galaxy still
collide with Andromeda
despite this expansion?
Good.
It'll collide before
that becomes a problem.
[LAUGHTER]
So as we continue to expand,
the strength of the dark energy
gains relative to the
strength of gravity.
And right now, we can still have
solar systems, and galaxies,
and nearby galaxies falling
towards one another.
You go a little too far away,
the expansion of the universe
is overriding the urge of the
galaxies to come together.
And that's where we get
our whole understanding
of the expanding universe.
But nearby galaxies,
our strength of gravity
strong enough so that the
expanding universe is not
overtaking this just yet.
And we will collide with
Andromeda in 6, 7 billion years
from now.
And we even have a word
for that new galaxy.
I thought it was very creative.
It's called the
Milkomeda or Milkomedia.
There's Andromeda
and the Milky Way--
Milkomedia.
It's a little clumsy.
But it's cute.
How close are we to finding
a unified equation that
explains all matter?
So I have a lot of
thoughts about that,
not that I have
any actual talent
to participate in that exercise.
but I think a lot about it.
And I just wonder--
that very question
contains a very deep bias,
that the universe
actually can be
described by a simple equation.
That's an interesting
philosophical bias.
You're imparting your own
sense of order and elegance
onto a very complex universe.
And I try to stay open minded.
Maybe the universe
is just messy.
Maybe the all forces don't
come together as one.
Maybe.
I'm going to allow for that.
You know why?
Because I studied
Johannes Kepler,
mathematician, German
mathematician, around the time
of Galileo, and Shakespeare,
and Queen Elizabeth.
A very fertile time in
Europe, around the year 1600.
He was sure-- because
he was a mathematician.
And he knew about
the Platonic solids.
You know about this if
you know any geometry.
There's only five
Platonic solids.
So these are solid shapes,
where every surface
is an identical polygon, an
identical, uniform polygon--
so a triangle.
So what do you have?
You can have-- four triangles
will make a pyramid.
That's one of the
five Platonic solids.
Another one is a cube.
Each side is a square.
If you keep doing this,
there are five of them,
it turns-- and no
more, and no fewer.
He loved math.
And he knew the universe
must be perfect.
God made it.
God's perfect.
Math is perfect.
So clearly the movement of
the planets around the Sun
must have-- and there's six
known planets, Mercury Venus,
Earth, Mars,
Jupiter, and Saturn.
And he has five of these solids.
So he decided to nest
the solids and then
put orbits in the
gaps between them
because if you have five
solids, you have six gaps,
or there's an
outer zone as well.
And if you do that, he's
saying, yeah, that's
got to be it because
that is beautiful,
because it is simple, because
that's how it must be.
And he spent 10 years
working on this.
And he said, no, it's not that.
And they're not perfect circles.
No, they're ellipses.
And they're different
shape ellipses at that.
And so the whole,
perfect philosophy
of what was guiding
his inquiry had
to be thrown out the window.
So maybe there's a
unified field theory
that captures all
the forces of nature,
simplifying everything in the
universe into one equation,
maybe.
But my read of history
tells me every time
we layer our own requirements
on what nature ought to be,
we end up with egg in our face.
So I'm not--
I'm not betting on it.
Should we put more effort
into colonizing Mars?
I would ask why would you
want to colonize Mars?
What's your goal?
I'm asking you right now?
Well, the idea of
decolonizing Mars
could help us from escaping
our climate Armageddon,
for instance.
OK, good.
Good.
So that's a common thought.
It makes a good headline, too.
And Elon Musk, and Carl
Sagan, and Stephen Hawking,
some very visible thinkers
in recent decades,
have made very
strong suggestions
that we should become at
least a two-planet species,
to ensure our survival
in case there's
some kind of catastrophe
or Armageddon rendering us
extinct on one of the planets.
That makes a good headline.
But I'm a little more
practical than that.
So I'm swimming
upstream in the ideas
I'm about to share with you.
They're not ideas.
They're just-- I'm just--
it's my sensibility is
different from that of others.
And here's why.
If you want to
colonize Mars now,
well, you can't because
you can't breathe the air.
So you have to build some
kind of habitat module.
So if you build
a habitat module,
and then you go to
Mars, well, you're
not really living on Mars.
You're living on Earth,
on Mars, because you just
created a habitat.
Well, that's like
going to Disneyland.
I don't mind visiting Mars,
and going to Disneyland,
spending a few weeks,
and then coming back.
Sure.
But you want to
colonize Mars and have
people live there
permanently, on a planet where
you can't breathe the air?
People say, well,
we had explorers
from the 15th
century who went out
not knowing where they'll land.
Sure.
Columbus visits the New World.
He gets off his ship.
He can breathe the air.
Other human beings are
there to greet him.
He can eat the fruit
growing on the trees.
And the trees are made of wood,
just like the trees in Europe.
If his ship breaks,
he can mend his ship.
If you crash land on Mars,
you can't go to the Home Depot
and get a new--
get pliers.
You can't get
anything, let alone not
being able to breathe the air.
So in order to really
become a two-planet species,
we have to terraform Mars.
terraform it.
I love me some
terraforming, don't get me--
I love it.
OK, great idea.
So you seed it with microbes
and certain chemistries,
that then operate on
their own chemical--
by their own chemical forces, to
generate oxygen. And all this.
OK.
So now we figure out
how to terraform Mars.
It's a stretch.
But it's not out of reach.
It's not out of our imagination.
Terraform Mars.
Now, we ship a
billion people there.
Now, we have our eggs in
two baskets instead of one.
Now, here's my issue.
Are you worried about
a killer asteroid?
It seems to me that
whatever effort
it took to terraform Mars
and ship a billion people
there is greater
than whatever effort
it would take to
deflect the asteroid.
I'm just thinking.
A asteroid is coming.
Let's deflect it.
No, first, left
terraform Mars and ship
a billion people there.
And then everyone here dies.
So that they've survived.
No, let's deflect the asteroid.
What else?
There's a killer virus
that goes around.
What investments will be
required in virology to create
a perfect antiviral serum?
Is that in reach?
I don't know.
I'm guessing it's less money,
less time, and less energy
to terraform Mars and ship
a billion people there.
And, finally, here we are,
we're trashing this planet.
Climate change
makes it unlivable.
Oh, my gosh.
What do we do?
So we terraform Mars and
ship a billion people there.
But wait a minute.
If we have the power
of geoengineering,
to turn Mars into
Earth, then we have
the power of geoengineering
to turn us back into Earth.
So all of these
arguments, I don't
see them having practical
meaning as a solution.
No.
I want to be a
two-planet species.
But the motivation shouldn't
be, so that half of us
can go there.
So that one of these
planets could go extinct.
No.
Save everybody.
Let's save every one.
Is that so wrong?
Let's just be a
two-planet species
because that's fun to do,
because that would be great.
That would be my
reason for doing it,
not as the imagined excuse
to save the species.
Speaking of climate
Armageddon, what
do you think we need to
do to save the planet?
Yeah.
So Armageddon-- when
I think of Armageddon,
I think of something more
catastrophic than what climate
change will bring to us.
So we are putting carbon
that has been long buried--
long buried in the
ground, turning that
into carbon dioxide
as the product
of burning fossil fuels.
So we are warming the Earth.
This will have
catastrophic consequences
to coastlines as we melt
the land-based glaciers.
And all that water
flows into the oceans.
And the ocean levels rise.
I live in New York City.
You can do the calculation.
If Greenland loses its ice,
and Antarctica loses its ice,
the water level will
rise to the left elbow
of the Statue of Liberty.
So basically, all of New
York City is under water.
And so is basically
every other major city
we've ever built in the
history of civilization
because cities were built where
there was commerce, where there
was transportation, where
there was-- and where's that?
That's on the water's edge.
So if all of what
founded civilization
is put in threat because of
these rising tide waters,
then, yeah, that's a
really bad future for us.
But we will survive
it as a species.
There's not-- it's
not an Armageddon.
It's a slow burn.
Actually, it's a fast burn.
And we're not going to be able
to respond nimbly enough to it.
We have to pick up
every coastal city
and move it inland a
hundred miles, or 50 miles.
Can we do that over decades?
No.
Because these cities
took centuries
to build, and to perfect, and
to develop, and to have them
function in the ways
that civilization
needs and requires.
Now, the reason I say
this there was a day
before we had fossil fuels, we--
Earth.
It's called the-- the
Carboniferous era of Earth,
all of that carbon
was plant life.
And Earth was hot.
We didn't have polar ice caps.
Life was doing just fine.
But humans had not
yet come along.
And humans had not
yet built cities
dependent on what we presumed
would be a stable climate.
So Earth will definitely
survive anything we do to it.
But our civilization, as we've
come to define it, will not.
We can call that Armageddon.
But there will be still
people who will survive.
But it'll be a really
ugly world at that point.
Neil, we are coming up
to the top of the hour.
So let me ask you
one last question.
Well, ask two questions.
I'll answer these
in half the time.
How about that?
Last two questions, OK.
So what do you see as a
landing on the Moon moment
for space-time,
something that transcends
national interests, something
that can unify the world?
Could unify the world?
A virus that can attack
any and all humans,
and would be a
pandemic, and we all
have to band
together to fight it.
Oh, that already happened.
And we didn't band together.
Oh, silly me.
Generally, people
band together when
they have a common
need and a common urge.
And the COVID virus
was a practice
run for invading aliens.
If an invading alien
wants to kill all humans.
It's time to get together folks.
Pool our resources.
Put aside your tribal ways.
In fact, let's
collect your tribalism
into one sense of the world.
And that one sense of
the world is that--
what race are you?
We are all the human race.
Now, let's fight
this common enemy.
We failed that.
The only success story was
the medical researchers
who developed the virus,
that the antiviral vaccine,
in record time.
That's why I wouldn't give it
quite an F of a COVID year.
I'd give it like a C plus.
And the fact that
it's not an F is
because we got
the vaccine going,
even though the
distribution had problems.
So why should we need a
Sputnik moment or Moon moment?
Why?
We know we all enjoyed it.
We know it transformed our
culture, our civilization,
our technologies.
It stoked our economies.
We know this.
Why do we have to feel
threatened again just to engage
in exploration on the frontier.
Knowing from past experience
that such exploration
can be transformative
to how we live?
So, yeah, that's my
answer to that question.
Thank you for that.
OK, last question.
Yeah.
If you could go back to
your 21-year-old self, which
is the age of many of the
students who are with us today,
what advice would you give?
I have what might be an unfair
satisfying answer for you.
Everything I am today,
everything, down to the tiniest
detail, is what it is
because throughout your life
you test things.
You experiment things.
And you learn.
You learn to do things
better-- or this didn't work.
And you learned this.
If someone goes back
in time and says
don't do that, that's
not going to work,
and they just tell
you, then that's not
part of your life experience.
That's just somebody handing
you their life experience.
So when I think of advice,
the advice is keep exploring.
Just keep doing
what you're doing.
And, yeah, there'll be
some failures in there.
You'll learn from those.
There'll be some successes.
You'll do more of that.
But you will have
experienced that on your own
as the consequence of
your own creativity.
And so it reminds me--
it's now-- it's an
apocryphal story.
But let me just
tell such a story.
So you have an immigrant who
comes to the United States
with $20 in their pocket.
Then they work hard.
And they struggle.
And they take odd jobs.
And then they finally
own a business
because they worked hard.
And they worked their way up.
And they had more-- they saved.
They own a business.
They get married.
They have children.
And then they have
multiple businesses.
And they become
really successful.
And it lives in a whole mansion.
But that person
struggled his entire life
trying to make ends meet, barely
getting food on the plate.
So now they're well off.
And they have kids.
And they make sure
that the kids do not
struggle the way they did.
They make sure the kids always
have food on their plate,
the way they did because I
don't want my kids to struggle
the way I did.
And then the kids grow up.
And they're 21 years old.
And they're deadbeats.
And then the parents say,
where did we go wrong?
We gave you everything
we didn't have.
That's where you went wrong.
Because you became what you
were because of the challenges
and struggles that you
faced in your life.
I don't-- I think we undervalue
struggle and what role it can
play in your future success,
in your future perspectives,
your outlooks, your
sense of the world,
especially since almost--
hardly anything worth
achieving will you end up
achieving without a struggle.
And if someone said here,
just do that, then you
don't have to struggle.
Well, OK, you made
your life easier.
Is that really what--
you just want an easy life?
Really?
OK.
Go ahead and get it.
You take your easy life.
What's going to
happen when there's
some stress in your life
or you'll freak out?
You won't know how to handle it.
You'll-- so I don't know.
I don't want to play
psychologist here.
But there are people who
are having trouble in school
because they're not
socialized in the right way.
And they're getting bullied.
So they take them
out of the school.
They put them in a
different school,
where everyone is
nice to each other.
And then when they go
get older, and they
get into the
workplace-- and then
there's the difficult
person in the other cubicle.
They don't know how to handle.
I keep thinking so much
of what also goes on
in school, beyond the
classwork, is learning how
to deal with difficult people.
And so, yeah-- so in terms
of advice, no, I wouldn't--
I don't know that I have advice.
Suppose I said, spend less time
doing athletics and more time--
because I did a lot of
athletics-- and more time
in your studies.
Maybe I could have done that.
But then I wouldn't have
this appreciation for sports
that I currently do.
And I wouldn't have
the conversations
that I have with
sports enthusiasts.
And I'm actually
like friends with--
well, strong acquaintances--
with the coach
of the Seattle Seahawks.
That's just fun.
and I have a fluency
in sports that
has enriched my life in ways
that wouldn't have been there
if I gave up all my
sports at the time.
And then I only had
my head in the books.
I used to--
I didn't doodle in class.
I don't have any art ability.
But I would play with my pen as
though I were a calligrapher.
And I would do fancy lettering.
And it turns out that The New
York Times, the banner head,
it's in Gothic.
A lot of the letters in The New
York Times appear in my name.
So I'd pull out those letters.
And I do them.
And there I am, like
I really should have
been paying attention in class.
And how does this accrue at all?
Well, I now have a
collection of fountain pens.
And I dip them in
ink, in ink bottles.
And when I signed my
books, I signed them
with a calligraphy pen.
And people like--
they like that.
I do that.
And it gets a gets
on the doorstep.
And it shows up on social
media, a little thing like that.
That's enriched my life.
It's enriched the
lives of others.
So don't tell me, future person,
what I should or shouldn't
be doing.
I'm perfectly
happy to experiment
and learn from it on my own.
Thank you for that, Neil.
Thank you for being with us.
Thank you for inspiring
us and encouraging us.
I look forward to
the next time you
and I have a chance to meet.
In the meantime,
we'll work really hard
on those self-driving cars.
Yes.
And, in fact, I want to get
you on my podcast, StarTalk.
The day the first self-driving
car, fully self-driving,
drives off the lot I want you
in my studio, to interview you.
Oh, one thing about your--
here's the advice to
give my 21-year-old self.
You ready?
I'm ready.
Make sure you actually do
learn from your mistakes.
That's the advice.
You don't want to ever make
the same mistake twice,
wasting your life, and
time, and everybody else's.
Awesome advice.
Thank you, Neil.
And Danielle, always
good to see you.
And I love you've got the
Horsehead Nebula behind you,
a little bit of
our universe there.
There's the horse's head.
You're blocking--
you're blocking
the thing that
gives it its name,
I just want you to know that.
That was a test for you.
OK, I know-- I know my sky.
Who do think you're
talking to here?
It was taken in my backyard.
Oh, it was.
Excellent, excellent.
So was this.
This was taken in my backyard.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, thank you
all for joining us.
Thank you, Neil.
OK, and everyone in MIT land,
stay strong, stay smart.
And you all know
that you're going
to become the
engines of tomorrow's
economies and tomorrow's
science literacy.
Just keep it going.
Absolutely.